good morning everybody nowhere to hide
is the government's message as they
reveal a 10-year plan to
to tackle drug crime in england and
wales gangs drug kingpins and even
middle-class users will be in their
sights reports this morning harsher
punishments could be dished out to deter
drug users such as removing their
passports and also their driving
licences the policing minister kit
multhouse is with us shortly first
here's some of the key announcements for
you
the government will invest 300 million
pounds in closing down gangs involved in
the drugs trade and the police will be
tasked with carrying out more than 6 000
disruptions against their activities
the strategy also outlines plans to
dismantle two thousand more county lines
distribution routes having already
closed around one and a half thousand in
the last two years
the strategy will also include the
largest ever funding increase for
tackling addiction and repeat offenses
after the home office said there are as
many as 300 000 heroin and crack cocaine
addicts in the country who are
responsible for almost half of all
acquisitive crimes such as burglaries
and thefts
joined now by the policing minister kit
mult house mr malta it's good to have
you with us this morning thank you for
joining us it's a ten year plan i
believe uh to combat drug related crime
could it really involve taking people's
past reports away from them
well in time yes i mean one of the
things we're focusing on to begin with
as you quite rightly said k is the
disproportionate amount of crime driven
by heroin and crack addicts but we also
need to reflect on the fact that there
are an awful lot of kind of lifestyle
users of cocaine and other drugs out
there who are driving much of the
violence and the the degradation that we
see from drugs overall and so what we're
going to do is publish a white paper
next year looking at what we can do to
try and turn them away from their
particular habits and that might involve
we hope uh interfering in their lives in
a way that brings about behavioral
change we've seen that in other parts of
government policy if you look at the
child support agency where people
i was responsible for that for a while
where people don't pay their support
courts do have a power to remove their
passport and their driving license these
are the kind of impositions on a kind of
lifestyle which we hope will bring about
behavior change over the next decade
if it's true that um 11 out of 12
locations tested in the house of commons
tested positive for class a drugs it
could be that some of your colleagues
find themselves in that position
well i i hope not there are obviously
several thousand people who work on the
estate and i'd be surprised that there
weren't some lifestyle uses of drugs
amongst them i have to say but what we
want to try and do is get to a situation
where the police and other authorities
are concentrating as much on that part
of the the drugs industry as you like if
you like as they are on crack and heroin
we need to make sure that we drive crime
numbers down overall the drugs industry
brings a lot of violence and degradation
and victimization into this country and
so attacking the supply which as you say
we've been doing with real vigor over
the last two years and accelerating that
over the next decade is critical but we
also have to look at demand demand at
the sharp end and heroin and crack users
who need to be treated for their
addiction as well as punished for their
crimes but also then moving on to the
much bigger group of those who are
driving this trade of powder coming from
across the world to the uk who are
driving that trade we need to turn them
away from as well and deal with their
offending in their behavior
you talk about lifestyle use it makes it
sound almost acceptable in the house of
commons
well it's not acceptable i mean i've
been struggling for a word people say
recreational they call it middle class
lifestyle whatever it is it's use that
is driving a lot of violence and a lot
of misery and there are lots of young
people as you will know in the capital
and elsewhere who are dying as part of
that trade being stabbed and killed you
know just in the last two years we've
rescued about 4 000 young people who've
been dragged into the drugs trade as
part of county lines and so the idea
that that kind of casual usage on a
saturday night is somehow a victimless
crime is is ridiculous and immoral and
we think that those people need to focus
on their behavior and we need to find a
way in society that we make it
unacceptable we impose on their
lifestyle in the same way that over the
last 20 to 30 years we've made drink
driving um uh unacceptable uh socially
we'd like to do the same with drugs
labour says it's your fault because
you've cut 100 million pounds from drug
treatment services since you came to
power
well obviously labour do a lot of uh
shouting and arguing about the past but
in truth the drugs industry has changed
um significantly over the last 10 years
we saw declines in usage uh cert to a
certain center decline in drug-related
crime and then that industry sort of
reacted right it did what most industry
would do it found a better product made
it cheaper new ways to distribute it
open new markets it's a very interesting
economic and business dynamic if you
like that meant that we needed to
address it now whatever three years ago
we commissioned dame carroll black to
have a look at drugs we're so alarmed
about it this strategy today is a
response to that but it builds on the
work we've been doing for the last two
years closing down these hundreds of
county lines across the country building
these recovery projects in places like
blackpool and norwich and middlesbrough
where we've brought everybody together
to turn lives around particularly those
on on heroin now we can turbo charge
that effort uh going forward you know
the critical change for us k is that we
recognize that this is a business right
what these drug dealers are doing is
trying to make money and if we can
interfere in their business both in
terms of reducing demand but breaking
the supply chains then hopefully we'll
drive activity down once and for all
okay let's talk about omicron i should
read that greek letter that none of us
thought we would ever know much more
about more than 50 percent rise in a day
of omicron cases but the impact on
deaths and hospitalizations has been
minimal um in other words there haven't
been any at this stage are we massively
overreacting
well i don't think we are we're being
proportionate and precautionary i mean
obviously we don't know completely what
this variant is going to do we know it
seems to be quite infectious but we
don't know yet exactly how
difficult it's going to be for people's
bodies to cope with that research is
ongoing we've got world-beating science
you know world-leading scientists who
are able to give us those answers over
the next two or three weeks in the
meantime what the prime minister said he
said look let's be careful right let's
take it steady let's wear masks in
certain areas where we think there's
likely to be uh transmission let's think
about travel uh more carefully and make
sure we do testing at the border to
restrict the virus coming in to buy us a
bit more time but fundamentally let's be
proportionate about it and get on with
our lives to a certain extent and try
and have as merry of christmas as we
possibly can so we're learning as we go
don't forget omicron is quite a way down
the alphabet that means between delta
and now we've been through a number of
variants that haven't got very far let's
see where this one goes but for the
moment steady
okay get you with your greek studying at
school um the us though has an awful lot
of scientists as well world class ii
including dr anthony fauci who's top of
the tree uh and he's told the leader
there that actually the travel ban
should be lifted um should we do the
same
well let's see as i say okay we've got
these amazing scientists at portland
down just on the edge of my constituency
who are doing that research right now
subjecting this virus to various tests
to see how it responds see what we know
we can learn about it and you know we
know that the work we do here in the uk
has been leading the world and informing
much of what the world does around this
virus so i have great confidence that
they'll give us a much clearer picture
of the next two weeks and until then
it feels to me doesn't it to you that we
should be cautious i think all i'm doing
is trying to clarify whether that if the
us is lifting the travel ban we are
saying okay good for you but we're not
going to do ours this side of christmas
well i think look we will be informed by
what comes out around the world what the
prime minister said the restrictions
will be reviewed in three weeks we need
a bit of time to form our own view about
what this virus is capable of then we'll
be able to look at the picture but as i
say review in well it'll now be in two
weeks won't it if the measures have been
put in place but it seems to me pretty
sensible and proportionate off the back
of the fact that we're in a much better
place than a lot of countries right the
decisions we made in the summer are
paying dividends now the booster program
is going really well 20 million people
now i think and rising i've got my
booster a week today hope you've had
yours k you know people are really
building their enthusiasm now for that
program
and if we carry on as we are then
hopefully all will be well
thank you for sharing with my audience
minister that i'm a lot older than you
uh pre-travel covid test no mine is
delayed mine's delayed because i had uh
i had covered well saying to minister
welcome
you weren't like yeah okay
yeah and i had mine early uh i didn't uh
pre-travel covered tests of day two
pre-departure tests why did we ever get
rid of those you know if we're only
going to put those in as a knee-jerk
when we get one of these variants and
it's already too late you know we need
to shut the door before the horse is
bolted
well no we have to be agile right we
have to recognize that all these things
are impositions on people's uh lives and
lifestyles they're obviously extra cost
and they cause difficulty for the travel
industry now we need to try and smooth
that as much as possible and be
proportionate about our response you
know i we've got family overseas we're
going to be traveling at christmas we're
having a test in and out in and out both
ways and it is a total pain especially
if you've got kids right so we
understand that and so we have to be
proportionate and make these judgments
at the right moment that's what we've
done and it feels to me as if in the
face of the unknown on this virus at the
moment for the next few weeks that's
where we need to broadly be but but
surely they're only ever effective if
they're left in place until we see the
back of this pandemic otherwise we're
saying oh it's already in we need to put
these day two test pre-detaching tests
in again it's too late by then
well i don't think it necessarily is i
mean obviously there's lots of testing
going on right we're in a great place on
testing people got used to it they
understand it but there are lots of
requirements around the world and
there's movements of virus around the
world that we need to pay attention to
so being agile it strikes me is the best
thing we want to try and live as normal
a life as we possibly can as the various
you know evolutions of this virus work
their way through the system and that
means that we're going to have to you
know duck and drake a bit i'm afraid now
prime minister is doing his best to help
us live as normal life as possible
recognizing that we don't know
everything we need to know yet about
different variations and that we might
need to do certain things like this as
as time goes on so i think the british
people generally accept that notion
okay here comes the christmas party
question um the uh police commissioner
the uh london police commissioner
christopher dick says reports of this
party or one of the parties at number 10
on the 18th of december have not been
reported to her
should they be
well i got i thought somebody had
reports i read in the paper that some
labour mps had reported this uh supposed
event um i mean as i say okay i know
nothing about it i've been assured by
number 10 that no rules were broken uh
if there was a gathering of any kind um
for your information at the time i was
kicking indoors in basildon with essex
police on a drugs gang uh which is what
i'm here to talk about um but yeah i
mean the police will have a look it's
for them to form a judgment she said
that it's not been reported to her
if it has been reported to the police
should they investigate
well that's a matter for the police i
mean the police get reports all day
every day of things that have happened
and they make a judgment about that and
it would be wrong for me as the policing
ministers to seek to have a view um
about the particular police
investigation you know we don't
generally comment on those things but
right you know we are assured that i've
been assured that everything she did
yesterday and didn't he was at the time
the justice secretary did yesterday
and also deputy prime minister he said
if any rules were broken
um then the any if there was a breach of
the rules then it should be investigated
and
if it happened indeed is what he said
but
if it did happen it would be a breach of
tier through tier three rules surely if
a crime potentially had been committed
it should at least be looked into by the
police
well you're asking me to answer a
hypothetical question about this issue
but my general view is that where crime
is reported the police should
investigate
um yeah i mean it's not really
answering the question is it and and you
know i know that uh the government is
also keen to have free speech over
privacy that's what we're being told
about at the moment so given that there
should be free speech over privacy
shouldn't the public know whether or not
there was a party at number 10.
well as i say the the questions have
been asked number 10 have said that
everything was complied with if reports
have been made to the police then
they'll no doubt have a look and form a
view about whether an offence was
committed or not as policing minister my
view is that if offences are committed
of any kind a report of the police there
should be an investigation by the police
they have to examine it and decide
whether they are going to pursue it and
that's a decision for them and not
something that i as a politician should
seek to influence whether it's but if
through your yeah i understand but it's
just it's just really irritating isn't
it for the public i mean if there was a
gathering of any sort that involved
people getting together having a drink
after work then that would have been a
breach of tier three rules on the 18th
of december last year and as a result it
would have been against the law so
surely the public should know whether
that happened or not
well i assume that any inquiry that is
made by the police will examine those
issues as i say number 10 are reassuring
everybody that all rules were complied
with during that period and i take that
reassurance at face value but no doubt
if the police are alerted they will have
a look and they'll form a view and we'll
all learn more about it in the days to
come which brings me back to my question
which is should the police be
investigating an alleged breach of tier
three rules
well the police should be investigating
anything that is a historic crime that
is reported to them
it's hard for me to go any further than
that okay because you know we don't
generally
comment on specific cases or inquiries
as as ministers that's not what proper
for us to do
but in terms of what the police's
responsibility is i think they're very
aware of that and reports are made that
inquiry should follow and let's see
where where it goes after that
okay fast forward a year
what can and we can't do this christmas
season
well obviously the the prime minister
said you can go about your normal
business but there are some specific
restrictions around mask wearing um so
you have to wear a mask in a retail
environment and on public transport
obviously some restrictions which we've
discussed on on travel in terms of
testing to make sure that we're not
importing uh the virus but otherwise uh
what he said is that we should go about
our business i will be taking my team uh
for a christmas uh dinner uh next week
uh out of the restaurant of the west end
to support that uh industry and also
have some fun at the same time i hope
you will be too we will be massed up
where appropriate and i'll be taking a
lateral flow test to make sure that i'm
a negative before a participant as i did
this morning before i came to see you
conscious as i am of your safety too
thank you very much i did exactly the
same uh before i came in this morning
minister how many people will be in your
party next week
i think it'll be six of us
okay and what are you doing on christmas
day will you be in a family gathering as
well we were speaking to sadie javed and
he was talking about if he was in a
group of maybe two or three hundred he
would take extra measures i'm not sure
how many of my viewers ever go to a
party of two or three hundred
uh well i if if you're interested i will
be overseas for christmas i hope um
having been tested appropriately on
either side the other half of my family
are canadian um so we'll be there we'll
be observing the the regulations in that
country
okay well good luck with your uh booster
job it doesn't hurt a bit and if you can
have your vac your flu vaccine at the
same time go for it
uh well i will try and do both i have to
say the first one i felt slightly dizzy
but then it's been fine so fingers
crossed yeah was it was it was it
astrazeneca though or what did you have
yeah i had azad twice yeah so that means
i think this time i'll get something
different there are pfizer so we'll see
how it how it goes but i have to say i
was one of the lucky ones when i had
covered i didn't have any symptoms uh i
did my 10 days you know constantly
testing myself to temperature wise but
nothing happens so fingers crossed it
stays the same i feel for people who've
and i've got lots of friends who've been
hammered hard uh by the virus it's been
really tough for a lot of people but the
booster is the way forward and i'm so
pleased that you've had yours game
and you too um keep well minister thank
you very much indeed for joining us
thank you
thanks a lot cheers